[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
JEREMY SHERMAN: Thank you.
Thank you.
It is a delight to be
here at tech Mecca,
talking with you all about
this very important question,
a question that is simple, huge,
soulful, strictly scientific,
techie, meaning-of-life-size.
And it's a question that we
ignore, shirk, skirt, ridicule,
and pretend we've
answered when we haven't.
An old family friend and I were
catching up with each other.
And he asked me what
I've been up to.
And I described the
question to him.
And he balked in a telling way.
He said, it sounds
like you've got way
too much time on your hands.
It's way over my pay scale.
It's a question that
can never be answered.
And it was answered last
week in a Facebook post
about quantum consciousness.
So I got all four of
them from him at once.
It is a simple question, much
simpler than any of the things
that you deal with.
And yet, it is a fairly
unfamiliar question.
People do tend to
balk at this question.
So the way I'm
going to do this is
I'm going to frame the question
and then pause for challenges,
kick the tires on
this thing, really
try to get clear on the
question, challenges,
questions, all of that, and
then give you a new proposed
answer, which is unlike anything
I've seen from other sources.
The question is, what
are striving selves?
I strive, therefore I am.
You know, Descartes said,
I think, therefore I am.
I'm going to go much
deeper than that.
I strive.
I try.
I make effort.
This doesn't make effort.
Computers don't
actually make effort.
They do work.
They do very useful work,
but they don't make effort.
They are not striving.
And I'll be more specific
about that in a minute.
You can call us any number of
things, and agent organism,
living being.
And I'm just going
to call us selves.
And I'm going to call us
all selves, that every one
of these organisms is striving.
It is doing work
for its own benefit.
"Striving" means not
going with the flow.
And you can see that here in
this self, going upstream.
And it's more than this.
It's more than just going
upstream because, really,
what's going on is we are
going against the flow
towards the
degeneration, everything
falling towards entropy,
randomness, disorder,
falling apart and petering out.
So a very simple,
straightforward question.
We don't.
We run to stay in place
like the Red Queen
in "Alice Through
the Looking Glass."
And it's happening right now,
unconsciously and unfelt,
striving, like what our
bodies are doing right now.
Right now, my body is
regenerating itself faster
than it degenerates.
And it's doing it
without me understanding
what it's doing, without
any awareness of it,
just like it does in bacteria.
That is, they don't
have consciousness.
They don't have feelings.
And yet, they are striving
against the tendency
to degenerate.
So really, we can distinguish
between two kinds of things--
the things that exist, lasting
as they degenerate, depending
on their durability, and
selves, which persist,
striving to regenerate.
Very big difference, as yet
unexplained by the sciences.
That's the question.
And as I said, machines
are not striving selves.
We engineer them for durability.
Computers aren't striving
selves, and striving selves
are not computers.
I adore computers.
I live on them.
I spend most of my time on them.
This is not a Luddite talking.
I'm not protesting against
the use of computers
as though they are heartless.
No, I think they're full of
heart, the way I use them.
But they are not striving.
So the question
comes down to this.
There's no magic added.
And yet, selves are
means-to-ends striving,
not just cause-and-effect
mechanism.
There's something
different about us
from nothing but chemistry.
So I rule out from
the start the idea
that there's some magic
non-thing thingie that gets
deposited into matter
that makes us come alive--
a soul, a spirit, a vital
force, or any of that.
None of that will work,
nor will the argument
that there's something about
all interactions, all material
interactions, all
cause and effect,
that's actually a little
bit means-to-ends, and you
collect enough of that together,
and suddenly, poof, it's
a suddenly striving self.
No, I'm ruling all of that out.
And also, I'm ruling out
the argument that all we are
is cause-and-effect mechanism,
which really does corner us
with a challenge.
What are striving selves?
There's a fundamental gap in our
research, scientific research.
Striving selves are inadmissible
in the physical sciences.
If you had a physics
professor who told you
that the moon strives to pull
on the tides for someone's
benefit, you'd think
there's something wrong.
But down the hall,
you've got a biologist,
or a social scientist,
who can talk all they
want about striving selves.
So there's this
fundamental rift.
Take these three terms,
absolutely essential
in biology.
You cannot do biology without
functional, basically function,
fittedness, and striving.
That's about selves.
That's about selves
engaging in what
I'll call self-directed
work, effort by selves,
for themselves, responsive
to their circumstances.
And the way it works for
continuity in the sciences
is that the lower
level scientists
have to explain what the
higher sciences assume.
And we've got a huge gap here.
Because chemistry does
not explain functional
fitted striving.
And yet, we totally
rely on it in the life
and social sciences.
So the approach I'm
going to promote
is that you start with
striving's patient zero,
the very first striving self.
You have to explain how
mattering could ever
emerge from matter, how you
ever get from chemistry to even
the most basic striving self.
And if you do that, you get
to reveal the bare essentials
without all of the
bells and whistles
that accumulate through
evolutionary history.
You start simple.
That is not how
we tend to do it.
We tend to do it through
cognitive science, which
starts way too high up.
It's like trying to explain
hair or from quills,
porcupine quills.
They are hair.
Consciousness is very much
a striving self's property,
just like quills are like hair.
But it's very specialized,
and it's highly evolved.
And it's also a little
bit, cognitive science,
like trying to explain striving
starting with wigs, which
is an artifact, a
computer as an artifact,
by which we can try
to determine what it
is about us that is striving.
You've probably heard of the
hard problem in consciousness
studies, which is
how do you ever
get qualia, the
experience, the feeling,
the sensation of things?
But cognitive science works
from a computational model
for what living is.
So I consider it the
made harder problem.
If you're going to try to go
from computation, which is not
striving to do anything,
and go straight to qualia,
you're going to have problems.
That's why I suggest we start
with patient zero, that is,
with the very first
possible striving self.
And I'll say this is a question
behind our biggest questions.
To reckon with consciousness,
mind, qualia, free will,
morality, mortality,
spirituality, astrobiology,
et cetera, start by explaining
how the first striving self
could emerge from chemistry.
So here is the mystery laid out.
We've got names.
We've got names for what selves
are, for their properties,
for their behaviors.
We've got nouns and
adjectives and verbs.
And they all remain as yet
unexplained by these terms
from the physical sciences.
So you can call us organisms,
subjects, agents, individuals,
living beings, creatures.
You can even call
us spirits or souls.
It doesn't actually
matter what we call them.
These are names that flag
what has yet to be explained.
They just are markers
that we use to say,
this is something we
have yet to explain.
And you've got all of
these properties and all
these behaviors
as yet unexplained
in the physical sciences.
Saying that you're
a striving self
is no more scientific
explanation
than saying you have a soul.
Both of them are just markers.
So naming is not explaining.
Here are some
solutions that we often
move towards since we have this
gap, and it goes unexplained.
And I'm going to suggest
that they don't work.
Natural selection--
there's an idea out there
that the universe was rolling
along with its natural laws,
and then, suddenly,
a new one enters
called natural selection,
and suddenly, it
gives rise to organisms.
Doesn't work.
Natural selection is actually
natural degeneration.
It's selves failing
to self-regenerate.
It explains the honing,
not what's honed.
To say that natural
selection explains life
is like saying that
erosion explains mountains.
Yeah, it explains
how they're sculpted,
but not what they are.
So I want to say natural
selection doesn't start life.
Life starts natural selection.
You actually have to have
striving selves before you have
evolution as we think of it.
Another idea is
molecular replication,
in particular, RNA molecules,
because they are so
important to us organisms now.
But the idea is that you would
get molecular replication.
What you've got
here are examples
of molecules not being created
from scratch as conservation
of matter.
It's transforming of molecules.
So you get these molecules
going through their chemical
reactions.
But the chemical
reactions can appear
to strive, but then
so can anything.
A river can look like it's
striving to get to the sea.
And actually, chemical
reactions like that
are just going with the flow.
So this idea that molecular
replication somehow
solves the problem will not do.
And energy gradients
degenerate first.
They peter out.
You saw that in these two
examples I just gave you.
But the material
order can remain,
degenerating more slowly.
It's still not striving selves.
How about genes?
Genes sometimes is used for
the molecules themselves,
as if a DNA molecule is a gene.
But mostly, what
we mean by it is
the sequences within the genes.
Sequences are not
striving selves,
but interpreted by them.
DNA, if you lay it on
a table, is lifeless,
so to argue that it's
the secret of life
seems to be missing something.
It's not this magical
molecule that's sometimes
depicted as the secret to life.
It's a little like saying the
text, which is also a sequence,
is striving to
tell you something.
Another striving self is telling
you something with their text,
but the text itself
is not actually
striving to tell you anything.
Or the alternative, which is
that it's just cause-and-effect
relationships, as if the
sequence, the genetic code,
which yields a one-to-one
correspondence--
a code is a material
cause-and-effect process--
is somehow all there is, which
is another popular notion
about it.
I want to be clear on this.
One of the places
where we get messed up
on this, and in the sciences,
and also in philosophy,
is to treat it all as causality.
Interpretation is not causality.
A stop sign doesn't cause you to
stop unless you crash into it.
We stop because we interpret
it, given our strivings, as
about traffic, for our benefit.
So interpretation is
radically different from cause
and effect.
Complexity, the reason I have
a frog on the cover of my book
is that in the book, I
pose the question, which
is more complex, a frog
or a frog smoothie.
Now, technically, a frog
smoothie is more complex.
There's poor correlation, and
there's almost no correlation
between the molecules,
once they're all shaken up,
once they've degenerated
with a blender.
But also, they would
degenerate anyway.
That's actually more
complex than the frog.
The frog has more regularities.
It would be easier
to describe, which
is the metric for complexity.
So we often get
ambiguous with this.
Is it more complex or
just harder to explain?
The frog is harder to explain,
and yet, less complex.
It's regularizations.
It's the orderliness
within a frog
that is so impressive
and so hard to explain.
How about AI?
Not striving, but
engineer-trained
to aid our striving.
If you connected a
jillion AI supercomputers
on a sterile planet,
what do you get?
You get a sterile planet.
That is, no quantity
of AI by itself
is going to yield
you striving selves.
Quantum mechanics, quantum
phenomena doesn't strive.
Striving selves persist at the
classical, non-quantum level.
Like jilted lovers,
many researchers
would rather not discuss it.
They dance around the
gap by equivocation,
basically talking out both
sides of their mouths.
I read these glorious
books by your neighbor,
for example, Robert
Sapolsky, who
wrote this wonderful
book called "Behave"
all about the biochemistry
of motivation.
I love these books.
And yet, they are still
dodging the question.
He'll talk about how a
molecule causes a motivation.
It's not clear how that happens.
And he doesn't seem
to be addressing it.
You get a book like
"Information," a theory--
what is it, "A History,
a Theory, a Flood,"
by James Gleick.
Wonderful book, which,
by the end of it,
claims that there's
information everywhere
and has always been, by the
end of the middle section.
And then he goes
into the last section
about how we're now experiencing
a flood of information.
Which is it?
Is it always everywhere?
Or is it something we can
experience a flood of?
If we experience a
flood of it, then
apparently we are interpreting
it in a different way
than we used to.
But the claim that
it's all information
is a kind of equivocation.
So information can be
talked about so it's just
Shannon reductions
and possibilities,
or as a difference that makes
a difference for a self that
is striving to stay
alive, to regenerate.
So that's the question.
And I want to hear
your challenges to it.
I want to hear you really
kick the tires on this,
really push back if you have
trouble with the question,
or if I haven't been
clear about the question.
And then I'll go on to
a new proposed answer.
No, intentionality would
be a subset of striving.
The words get really
squirrelly in here.
That is, they carry
a lot of baggage.
In my last presentation at
biosemiotics conference,
I called it trying,
which tends to imply
a kind of a
psychological intention,
a will, a conscious effort.
So I've ended up gravitating
to striving for two reasons.
One, it's fairly clean on this
question of ghost and machine.
There's a tendency
in this research to--
I think of it like
walking a tightrope line,
this question here, because
you can fall off into ghost,
basically homuncular-- that is,
you're anthropomorphizing what
goes on--
or into machine, mechanics,
cause and effect.
So how you ride that is
difficult with the words
we've got.
There are definitions
of intentionality
that would be broad enough,
that would cover what all living
beings do, but that's not
the vernacular use of it.
And we usually think of
it as something willed
by a conscious, feeling being.
But yes, it is included in here.
And by the way, I am not
just striving to regenerate.
I'm striving, for example,
to communicate an idea.
That is, by now, humans
have all sorts of headroom
and all sorts of distractions,
other kinds of intentions.
But if you want to
get at patient zero,
you start with the
most basic, which
is pushing against this
tendency to fall apart.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
artificial intelligence
and the limitations thereof,
that you could hook up
a large number of artificial
intelligence machines,
and that you would still not
get a striving self out of it.
JEREMY SHERMAN: Yes, nicely put.
AUDIENCE: One of the
ways that we understand
artificial intelligence
today is just
a whole bunch of linear
algebra and neural networks.
And that is very
much a calculator.
Are you saying by that that
artificial intelligence
of today could not be
a construct of that?
Or could it be never that?
JEREMY SHERMAN: No, I'm
actually saying of today.
And this is an important point.
It's actually my takeaway.
That is, once you
understand patient zero,
you have a new
angle on AI, which
I wouldn't know about because
I'm not an expert on it.
But I do think there's
potential for it.
And there's someone
in the audience
who's paying close
attention to that potential.
Anton right here.
There we go.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JEREMY SHERMAN: Yes.
It's just not yet.
AUDIENCE: So are you counting
viruses as striving or not?
JEREMY SHERMAN: It's
a great question.
And I would say yes.
But to do that, I can't
just work from impressions.
I have to give an
argument for that.
So it's a difficult
argument and debatable.
It's not altogether clear.
The model I will give
you for patient zero
is like a non-parasitic
virus, without DNA.
It's really got to
be simple, and yet,
not impressionistic to do it.
But yes, there is something
about them that does seem--
we talked this back and
forth, me and this guy,
and colleagues,
including John and Anton.
We explore this and wonder about
whether viruses count or not.
But we think they probably do.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So regarding
your slide on genes--
JEREMY SHERMAN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: --how would
you respond to the idea
that a chicken is an egg's
way of making another egg,
and that it's not the DNA
that is the striving self,
but rather, the coupled system
between a ribosome and the RNA.
JEREMY SHERMAN:
Well, even still,
if you put ribosome and
RNA naked on a table,
they're not going to
be a striving self.
But you're onto something.
One of the things that life has
to do is it has to replicate.
It has to reproduce.
O use reproduce rather than
replicate because replicate
is a kind of thing you can
do without paying attention
to the work involved.
You know, those chemicals
were replicating,
in effect, over there.
No, reproducing takes work.
So we have to explain
the work that selves do.
You know, we go back and
forth between saying,
I have this body,
and I am this body.
I'm going to argue that
what I am isn't my body.
The body remains
there after I'm dead.
It's still all right
there, the energy,
the material, the organization.
And yet, I'm gone.
So I have to be able
to explain that and not
resort to phantoms,
not resort to ghosts.
This is the challenge.
This is what I'm going to try
to do in this next little bit.
But yes, you take a sequence,
or you take a coding process,
extract it from biology, it's
not the striving self either.
You just got to keep on--
it's a process of
elimination, saying, well--
and that's basically what I
was going through with those
solutions that don't.
Each of those have
been tempting,
and I'm arguing each
of those don't cut it.
AUDIENCE: OK, so let's say you
have a very simple organism
like a non-parasitic
virus that you mentioned,
which is striving.
Now, if we could simulate
that with sufficient fidelity,
would the simulation
then be striving?
JEREMY SHERMAN: I'm
delighted you bring that up.
I want to propose a
contrast between simulation
and emulation.
Simulation is done with
cause and effect, formalisms,
schematics, that sort
of thing, basically,
arrows and pointers
moving from node
to node by my version of it.
That is, you are modeling the
consequences of some behavior.
Emulating would be actually
showing how the behavior works.
And it's different
from modeling it.
And I'm going to
give you an example.
Two slides after this is
going to be Anton's emulation
of the process I'm describing.
If you can emulate
it, yes, you're
well along to being
able to understand it.
But you have to work
with the world as it is.
And it's not a bunch of
cause-and-effect arrows
and nodes, where you
get to label the node
and just talk about them
as pointing this way.
I'll be saying a little
bit more about this.
Emulation, I'm going to
argue, is something different,
and totally
achievable at Google.
So that's one of
the reasons why I'm
interested in presenting here.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I mean, well, we'll see.
But I don't completely buy the
difference between simulation
and emulation.
It seems like a--
JEREMY SHERMAN: Good.
And I haven't really
delivered on it yet.
So let me see--
I look forward to your
questions and challenges after.
AUDIENCE: OK.
JEREMY SHERMAN: OK?
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
JEREMY SHERMAN: OK, so
this is Terrence Deacon.
I had met him shortly after
this book had come out,
"The Symbolic Species."
He's spent 20 years as a
neuroscientist at Harvard
trying to understand
the emergence
and consequences of us having
language, "The Symbolic
Species."
And he had just moved on
to another question, which
culminated in this book in 2011
called "Incomplete Nature, How
Mind Emerged from Matter,"
famously a challenging book
to read, difficult to read.
So my effort is to distill it
and some of this into my book.
I think of him as a
natural philosopher,
which is what scientists
were originally called.
He's a scientist.
And yet, he's dealing with
philosophical questions,
questions that scientists
often don't get around to like,
what is a striving self, or how
does language actually emerge.
He's also a very easy
person to talk to.
We have a meeting at his
house every couple of weeks,
open to whoever is interested.
That's how Anton got involved.
No, Anton actually read
"Incomplete Nature"
and decided he wanted to model
or emulate the process that he
proposes in here.
John also joined up
through that meeting.
We just get together
and explore this stuff.
It's delightful.
It's easy.
It's apolitical.
The guys never pulled
rank on me in 21 years.
We just talk we work
on the problems.
It's a delight.
So here's the question
as I posed it before.
"Striving selves are something
different from nothing
but chemistry.
What, starting
with patient zero?"
And here, I'm going to give
you a grotesquely simplified
solution.
It's a chain reaction that
generates chain reaction seeds.
I'm not sure that Terry would
like that, but it gets at it.
And here is Anton's beginnings
of the emulation of it.
That is, he's imagining
a chain reaction.
He's modeling a chain
reaction with all
of the stochastics involved.
And these seeds
forming along the way,
they are color coded
to represent their,
in effect, viability.
And this is very early
days for this research,
but he sees this as
a possibility for how
we can get at the narrowing
in on the kinds of molecules
that might have made
this process possible.
You'll notice that I said
that these were something
like non-parasitic viruses.
But there's no DNA
in these things.
The reading of sequences in
the service of your striving
is not the kind of thing
you can imagine easily
coming about spontaneously
out of chemistry.
It's a very complicated process.
Terry has a model for
how we could get there.
But we're starting
simpler than that.
And as I said, simple,
but not impressionistic.
OK, now let me back up and
tell you how I got there,
how we get there, to your
to-don'ts, basically,
your experience of life.
You focus rather than dithering.
You could have done
dozens of other things
right now during your hour here.
But you chose to be here.
And you're not just everywhere.
You're doing focused work.
Your focus is a product of
self-control, everything
you prevent yourself from doing
consciously and unconsciously.
And above all, you focus on
preventing the degeneration
of your ability to focus.
So I'm going to be arguing
that you are a prevention that
prevents itself from ending.
It's a process of
elimination logic,
very different from
the arrow kind of logic
we use in schematics
and formalizations.
And it's the insight behind a
lot of very big breakthroughs.
Pay attention to
what's eliminated.
Darwin, natural selection--
to explain fitness,
attend to the
non-survival of the unfit.
Shannon, signal theory--
to explain signals sent,
attend to signals not sent.
Ashby, H. Ross Ashby, who coined
the term "self-organization"--
to explain increased order,
attend to emergent constraint
on disorder.
I'm going to have to say more
about emergent constraint.
Here are two quotes from
him that I like a lot.
"A self-organizing system
spontaneously reduces
the number of its
potential states."
"Observe what might have
happened, but did not."
Here's an example, an
intuitive example of it,
threading through a crowd and
others threading around you.
You'll get these
streams of people
who are taking the path
of least resistance
that emerge by a process
of path elimination.
Now, these are striving
selves, so it doesn't really
count if we want to
look for patient zero.
But there are, of course, plenty
of non-living self-organization
processes.
Now, the term
"self-organization"
is problematic.
We were talking a minute
ago about problematic terms
like "intention."
It suggests a self
trying to organize it.
And there are
plenty of people who
have moved in that direction,
talking as though if you just
get self-organization going,
and it gets complicated enough,
then you've got a striving self.
I actually call it
emergent regularization.
It's a constraint process.
And whirlpools are an example.
Auto-assembly, like
crystal formation,
and autocatalysis about
which I'll say more now,
because they're
essential to our model.
Auto-assembly is basically
crystal formation,
but all sorts of other processes
as well-- lipid membranes,
for example, which are
bubbles, or capsids,
which will be crucial here.
They're like viral shells.
They're not actually
constructed deliberately.
They're not part of
the striving process.
They actually fall together
just like crystals do.
They fall to resting states.
And their resting states, given
their complementary molecular
geometry, will yield you
regularized sheets, shells,
and tubes.
So these are very exciting.
Remember, we are
trying to figure out
how to explain the frog.
Well, the frog is
full of regularity.
So we might look
to this process,
auto-assembly, as a step towards
life, towards striving selves.
Autocatalysis is
basically a chain reaction
that grows a population
of multiple catalysts
that are all, in effect,
producing each other.
It's a population
explosion that grows,
depletes the resources
that it depends upon,
and then dissipates.
So if you imagine you've got
these two molecules, x and y.
And in this super
simplification of it,
they are both
transforming reactants--
I didn't get specific
about the reactants--
into more of each other.
An X transforms an R into a
Y. And a Y transforms an R
into an X. And you get
this population explosion
of X's and Y's.
But in the meantime, you're
depleting all the R's.
And you end up with a
dissipation of the molecules.
And the thing about
this autocatalysis
is, it's more likely to start if
you've got a cluster of the X's
and Y's to start it.
Yes, it could start
with one X producing
one Y that then
produces another X.
But it's way more
likely to start
if you've got a cluster
of them in close range.
And often with
byproducts-- for example,
an X might split an R into
a Y in some other molecule,
which would also be crucial
to this explanation.
Self-organization--
so like I said,
some people think that
self-organization is enough.
It's a variation on the
complexity argument.
If you get enough of this kind
of emergent regularization,
self-organization, suddenly,
it becomes a striving self.
We don't think so.
It goes with the flow
towards overall degeneration,
and selves don't.
They strive to regenerate.
But still, this concept
of emergent constraint,
that is, reduced
possibilities emerging
throughout a dynamic process,
is of interest to us.
And we think
there's a way to get
at the origin, the patient zero
of striving selves, through it.
So just to be clear on
the general principle,
the whole is less than the sum
of its parts possibilities.
Any of those people threading
their way through the crowd
could have moved in a
whole lot more directions,
but those directions are
reduced through the congestion.
And they end up taking
paths of least resistance.
As some probabilities
become less likely,
others become more likely.
What's presented is a
product of what's prevented.
And so we got that
throughout the--
Darwin, Shannon, Ashby are all
playing with this key insight.
And basically, what we're
doing is applying it
to this question, what
is a striving self?
If it's not your body, if it's
not your DNA and ribosomes,
what is it?
So we think of
self-regeneration as possibly
a higher-level
emergent constraint.
So we've come up with a testable
hypothesis for how coupled
self-organizing processes could
prevent each other from ending.
And like I've said, it has
to be simple and yet not
impressionistic.
I don't get to say, well,
it looks like it's striving.
It actually has to be doing
work on its own behalf, fit
to its own environment.
Requirements for
self-generation, very basic.
If you think about,
OK, everything's
degenerating, how would you
keep yourself from degenerating,
you'd need self-repair,
regenerating
whatever degenerates.
You'd need self-protection, that
is, preventing degeneration.
And you'd need
self-reproduction,
because, eventually,
you will degenerate,
and you need lineages of
self-generating striving selves
that have the capacity to
self-repair and self-protect.
And out of these
three, you end up
with this interesting
challenge, what
I call selective interaction.
We all deal with it.
But it had to be there
at the beginning of life.
That is, in order to do any
of this generative work,
you need to take in
energy and resources
and put out waste products.
And at the same time,
to prevent degeneration,
you have to not do that.
So you've got this going on
from the origins of life.
And that's a challenge for
origins of life research
because the kinds of selective
membranes that we all rely
on, that let in some stuff
and not others-- pores,
and orifices, and all that--
you're not going to get that
by chance, just a lucky chance
that lets in all
the right stuff,
lets out all the
right stuff, doesn't
let in all the
wrong stuff, doesn't
let in all the wrong stuff.
That is a
origins-of-life theory.
And origins of
striving selves has
to be striving successfully,
outpacing the tendency
to degenerate from day one, that
it has to be able to do that.
And this is a challenge,
the selective interaction.
By the way, you're
still doing all of this.
Obviously, self-repair,
you're striving
to keep fit and healthy,
sometimes consciously,
sometimes not consciously.
Self-protection, you're
regenerating skin,
staying clothed with
a roof over your head.
Self-reproduction, kids maybe.
And selective interaction,
which has gotten very elaborate
for human beings.
There's a little taste of
it in this room right now.
I'm suggesting something that
you can either absorb or avoid.
People do all the time.
We're always trying to
figure out what to take
and what not to take in at
many levels, from, you can say,
the immune system to
our mouths all of this.
All of it's still going on.
So here, finally, is that model
that I mentioned early on.
And we got the emulation
of it from Anton.
Here it is, the autogen,
meaning the self-regenerator.
Imagine you've got one
of those chain reaction
processes, the autocatalysis,
but its byproduct
happens to be one of
those capsid molecules.
So while it's chain reacting,
in the midst of that chain
reaction, it's
putting out molecules
that will form the
equivalent of virus shells.
Not trying form
them, they just form.
They fall together.
That's the auto-assembly.
So you've got to
complementarity between the two,
where you get a chain
reaction, and then you've
got these shells
that encapsulate what
I call starter kits or
seeds, that if they break
open in the presence
of more reactants
can resume the autocatalysis,
the chain reaction,
and resume producing seeds.
OK, so let's take
a look at this.
You got the reactant.
You've got a cluster of
these catalysts in here.
The purple molecules
are the capsids.
It breaks open.
Let's say a big
molecule hits it.
And it's got spill out
into the reactants,
which generates a
whole lot more seeds,
X's and Y's, that end up,
by happenstance, captured
within more of these shells.
That's the seeds
or starter kits.
Very simple model.
Is there self-regeneration?
Well, it's repairing the
seeds as they degenerate.
And the capsids protect
against degeneration.
It generates varied and
evolvable autogen lineages,
and there's selective
interaction, though not quite.
It's not actually choosing
when to be open and closed.
I'll explain how we
get there in a minute.
But at least you
have an alternation.
And the alternation
is crucial, given
that one of the
things that has to fit
is environments where reactants
are only sometimes present.
We think of this thing like a
ratchet it grows for a while,
and then it locks down.
And while it's locked down,
it can survive in environments
where there are no reactants.
That's why it's useful to have
seeds or starter kits that
are enclosed and basically
static at that point.
So it's functional in
that it self-repairs
when broken for its own sake.
Remember, here's a good
place to not be thinking
about intentionality.
It's not trying to.
It doesn't care.
It's that conscious.
It's not willing all of that.
And yet, we have to
start at that level
if we're really
going to understand
that the self-repair benefits
the lineage of autogens.
It's fitted, as I've mentioned.
It's striving.
When seeds are broken, autogens
respond with autocatalytic work
that regenerate seeds.
Here's an example of
how it might evolve.
We argue that, at
this point, you
have found a way to outpace the
tendency towards degeneration.
It breaks open.
Other molecules get into it.
We have discovered a way
in which it can self-purge.
That is, it will tend
to get rid of molecules
that don't facilitate it.
It breaks open, and
the molecules of copy
are the X's and Y's, not the
other molecules that are kind
of strays that enter into it.
So there's a little bit of
self-purging at this point.
But imagine that you end
up not with a Y but a Z,
and the Z happens to have
a different byproduct,
a different capsid molecule
that's a little rougher
on the outside.
And the R's actually
stick to it,
making the overall seed rougher,
more likely to break open.
Now, this is the kind
of thing we can emulate.
I'm not saying
this is the answer.
But it does show the kinds
of things that could evolve.
And it is an
attempt to show how,
from nothing but
physics and chemistry,
you could actually get a
striving self that would then
have the capacity to evolve.
So you can see that
this one actually begins
to have selective interaction.
It is more likely to open
in the presence of reactants
than in the absence
of reactants.
And then as I
mentioned earlier, we
have a model for
how you'd end up
with a template molecule,
a molecule like DNA or RNA
that has a sequence
that is actually
functional for
the striving self.
But we would argue, given
the complexity of making
use of a sequence,
you really have
to start with striving
selves if you're
going to get to the level where
you can actually use DNA and/or
RNA.
OK, so what's a striving self?
It's not a ghost.
It's not something
added to chemistry.
It's not mechanism.
It's not the material energy,
cause-and-effect work,
or organization.
It's a self-regenerative
emergent constraint,
a synergistic coupling between
two self-organization processes
that prevent each
other's degeneration.
What is the self then?
What is a striving self, if
you were to work all the way up
to all of us?
I would argue that we are a
constraint that channels energy
into work that prevents the
constraint's degeneration
and that it came about
through a synergy between two
self-organizing processes that
prevent each other from ending.
Your whole is less than
the sum of your parts'
independent possibilities.
So I come back to
emergent constraints
because I think it may have the
most application in thinking
here about how to move
AI and other technologies
beyond where we already
are, to really push it.
Observe what might have
happened, but did not--
emergent regularization,
as I said,
self-organization is
go-with-the-flow, local,
temporary generation of
energetic and material
regularities.
Emergent
self-regeneration, though,
is selves striving
against the flow
to prevent their
own degeneration.
And it happens through
this synergistic coupling,
where both of them stop
the other from failing.
Autocatalysis, remember, it
grows and then dissipates,
while the capsids keep it from
losing all of its potential
before it dissipates.
And capsids will break
open and dissipate as well,
but the autogen
replenishes the supply
of capsid molecules, these
molecules that form the shells.
In general, though, there's
a methodological question
or proposition I want to make.
Life isn't schematic or formal
like our engineering and math
simulations.
It's running gauntlets, selves
constraining possibilities
to prevent dying.
It's somehow figuring out how
any organism does anything
like this, running
through the constraints
because it is fitted
to the constraints.
It has, internal to
itself, an agency
that enables it to avoid all
of the risks of degeneration.
And in general, I find
that, across the fields--
in philosophy, in
programming, just
across the fields-- we're
still using models that,
in one way or another, apply
point A to point B, kind
of a Euclidean approach,
that I'm going to say
is not quite how it works.
Everything is
random at the start.
And somehow, life
figures out how
to narrow in on possibilities.
It's processes of elimination.
OK, so just these two takeaways.
To push the tech envelope,
pay attention to how tech
simulates but doesn't yet
emulate striving selves.
And that's the thing
we can talk about.
And the other is to
emulate, pay attention
to emergent constraints,
not schematic arrowing,
but dynamic narrowing
of possibilities.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Anybody have any
questions and challenges?
AUDIENCE: So one of the
interesting consequences
of the way that you've
presented this is that is it--
you mentioned it works
on multiple levels,
at the immune system
level or the organization.
Is there any bias in
this for observing this
at any particular level?
Because you could look
at it from an ant cell
to an ant organism,
as we understand it,
to an ant colony, to
the super colony that
covers California
versus humanity's cell,
or a person standing here, or
their neighborhood, community,
society.
JEREMY SHERMAN: Yes, wonderful.
Great question.
The people who are
doing this research
come at it from a variety
of different angles.
My background's in
the social sciences,
and most of what I write
is in the social sciences.
And yet, it's all under the
influence of this model by now.
I mean, the thousand
articles I've written,
they're all based on this.
The political work,
the moral work
I do as a psychoproctologist,
it's all based on this.
In our own research, though, we
keep focusing on patient zero.
We are kind of
obsessed at that level.
And we also have people
who come into the group
with some intuition,
some gut assumption
that they want to uphold.
They're kind of tethered to it.
And they come to this work
like it's a Rorschach blot.
And they start to say,
wow, this proves that I
was right about this thing.
I am delighted with how
we managed to keep that
from influencing the work.
And a lot of this is
because Terry is a nerd.
He's dogged about this question.
He wants to get it right.
I've seen him change
his mind lots.
I've changed his
minds about things,
and he's way more advanced
academically than me.
He's not interested in
the status questions.
He's not interested in--
I don't see in him
any ax to grind.
Yes, he would like life
to continue striving.
But no, I haven't
seen that influence.
We've got some biologists in
the group that are primarily
interested in multicellularity.
We've got all
sorts of people who
are interested in
the implications
of this narrowing-not-arrowing
approach
to all levels of living systems.
We've got a few guys who
are really interested in
whether organizations
are organisms.
And yeah, they can look like
it, but are they really?
So we have fussed
about that a lot.
I, one point, was writing as
though they were, that there
were these super-organisms.
And Terry laid out the
challenges to that.
Just because it gives that
impression, it probably isn't.
Let's look at what is the
criteria by which you could
say that something is actually
a striving self as compared
to an agglomeration
of striving selves
that are achieving things?
So I love the way we employ
the power of neutral thinking
to the best of our abilities.
And by the way, you cannot work
in science without the possibly
that you will have spent
your entire life barking up
the wrong tree.
So I have no idea
whether this is right.
But I am enthusiastic
about the way
that it addresses a
question freshly framed.
AUDIENCE: I feel a
little bit like you've
reduced the original
question to something which
is a lot more
tractable and, I think,
is a less satisfying question.
But for a bigger question,
where does consciousness
fit into this?
JEREMY SHERMAN: Well,
Terry's a neuroscientist.
He's got theories about this.
There are hunches about
how you'd actually get
to qualia and consciousness.
I just got back from the
biannual Tucson conference
on the science of consciousness.
And it's remarkable
how much there
they are talking as though
everything is conscious.
And then there's some
kind of quantum leap.
It crosses a threshold
and then it becomes
conscious in ways we recognize.
Then you've got
people who are saying
that there is no consciousness.
And there's people who are
talking about it coming out
at the quantum level.
All this sort of
stuff, very satisfying.
I don't think realistic at all.
So it's one of the
questions that we
deal with, you know, Terry
having spent the first 20
years working on how language
affects consciousness.
I have hunches
about consciousness
being the really big difference.
And I'm especially interested
in how it changes adaptation.
That is, life has been
adapting for 3.8 billion years.
And now, we're doing it under
the distorting influence
of language, which makes us like
these chronically hallucinating
mammals with all sorts of
interesting consequences,
positive and negative.
And how to manage
them, it's a focus
of another whole book of mine.
But "satisfying" is a
really key word here.
Yes, in many ways, this has
to be simpler because you
don't get any engineering.
You don't have life
already existing.
And you don't get that the
light of the impression that you
have discovered how life
as you experience it works.
It's going to have to be a
simple solution at this level.
And yet, I would argue that
whether you buy this solution,
this proposed answer
to it, or not,
that's the level to work on it
because if you cannot explain
striving selves, you are not
going to be able to get beyond
explaining hair
with wigs or quills.
You're way up at the high levels
and assuming or assuming away
all sorts of stuff
at the lower levels.
AUDIENCE: Is there a point at
which awareness, or awareness
of awareness, becomes
significant or important
to the definition.
JEREMY SHERMAN: Yeah, it's
another area where we explore.
We think that, basically,
what we're describing here
is what Terry calls
"vegetative sentience."
I don't like the
word "sentience"
because it implies feeling.
I like "responsiveness."
He and I have been
working on how
to find words that don't
carry a bunch of baggage
and yet nail it.
So responsiveness, there's
responsiveness from the
get go with these.
If they break open, they
respond by doing work
to regenerate themselves,
to repair themselves.
Then there's a feeling,
which is more like sentience.
And then there's
conceptualizing.
These are the three that are
of greatest interest to us.
And yes, there are a bunch
of wonderful articles
by Terry and
colleagues about how
it works at the higher levels.
But again, for
this presentation,
I really want to
concentrate on patients
zero, because if we
can't explain him,
we're groping in the dark.
AUDIENCE: I take it too morbid.
But where does death
fall into that cycle
of regenerating and this--
JEREMY SHERMAN: Death?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JEREMY SHERMAN:
Wonderful question.
I am chronophobic.
I am chronophilic.
Death fascinates me.
I memorize poems about it.
Where does it fit
into this model?
What is dying?
When one of these
breaks apart or opens
in the presence of
reactants, what is dying
is not the material form.
The material form
can actually change
over openings and closings.
That is, several generations
down the line, one
of these seeds may have
no molecules in continuity
with the original one.
And it's not the energy.
The energy's coming
from the outside.
What is being lost
is the constraint.
When I die, my molecules are
free to do way more things.
Life is not an add-on to
physics and chemistry.
It's a subset.
It's a self-constrained
subset, that
is, me reducing
the possibilities
as long as I live.
And as the synergies, by
now, through evolution, I've
accumulated vast
quantities of synergies,
like the one we started
with, the complementarity,
where they both prevent
each other from ending--
we do that all the
time in our bodies
at so many different
levels, it's a marvel.
It's many PhDs.
But what you lose
is the constraint.
And suddenly, the
molecules are free.
I read recently Dan Brown's
new book on origins of life.
And he tries to make
that a pretty picture, as
if everything is
moving towards entropy,
and that means
that they're free,
and that means that they're
shining their light everywhere
in the world.
That is not how entropy works.
Entropy is things falling apart.
And if life was about
maximizing entropy,
which is also a popular
notion in this book--
Jeremy England brings this up--
then let's just
explode the sucker.
I mean, if you want
maximum entropy,
there are faster ways
to do it than we do it,
we living beings.
We actually sequester energy.
That's one of the reasons
why we've got petrochemicals.
So the thing to pay
attention to here--
I was trying to get to it
in the last two slides--
is that what I am is a
constraint on what happens.
And when those constraints
start to fail, I lose my agency.
And at that point, I'm
dead, and the molecules
are free to be in a whole
lot more configurations.
And often, with offspring.
In fact, my fellow grandfather
of my grandchild is right here.
Talk about offspring.
This is my first time
at hecca tech Mecca.
I am delighted to be here.
I'm grateful that you
were able to give me
your attention for this time.
And do feel free to get in
touch about any of this.
If questions, and challenges,
and kickings of the tire
come to you tonight or
any time, I'm around.
OK?
Very local in Berkeley.
And thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]